Welcome back everyone riddle me this the less
of them you have the more one is worth this is
going to be my video for the batman movie ending
the post credit scene yes there is a post credit
scene it's not quite what you expect but it
is still a post-credits scene in that very
special cameo scene that everybody's going to
be talking about for the next several weeks
gotham does love a comeback story so we'll break
it all down including the additional deleted scene
with that special quote-unquote character there
were more scenes of him in the longer cut of the
film like this four hour cut that matt reeves was
hyping up if you're new to the channel we're doing
a giveaway for movie tickets so that you can go
back and see it again a billion times because
it was awesome all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your predictions for what
matt reeves is going to do with that special new
character in the sequel movies big spoiler warning
for the batman movie if you have not seen it yet
we'll be talking about the end of the movie the
special post-credits scene the special cameo
scenes but at the end of the movie the batman
goes to arkham asylum to confront the riddler
and find out why he kept writing to him for the
entire film and the riddler almost pulls a full-on
batman hush twist revealing his secret identity
so batman thinks during their conversation the
riddler keeps talking about bruce wayne he keeps
repeating the line bruce wayne bruce wayne over
and over he thinks the riddler is going to out
his identity to the public making himself famous
in the process there were also a lot of thomas
elliott easter eggs from the batman hush storyline
the reporter who carmine falcone killed for thomas
wayne was named elliot and during the special
rataalada viral videos that the riddler posted
about thomas wayne he wrote the words hush
all over the video so if you got batman hush
vibes that was on purpose and jeff loeb who wrote
batman hush was matt reeves screenwriting teacher
back in college so hush and long halloween easter
eggs really coming full circle in the movie here
i'm sure jeff loeb was watching the movie pulling
a full-on leonardo dicaprio meme just pointing
at the screen every five minutes but after the
batman solves the riddler's final riddle about
the attack on mayor bella rayal's election that
whole group of riddlers on his viral social media
site ratsalada.com with the password locked
videos he kept posting was meant to be a big q
anon reference for the real live january 6 capital
attack in 2020 for the real life u.s presidential
election last year if you got a lot of q anon
vibes that was on purpose a lot of the names
in the chat on those videos when they popped up on
screen had anon in the title the riddler was meant
to inspire all these other conspiracy theorists
to attack belarus and the people of gotham to get
their own version of quote-unquote vengeance one
of the riddler's followers even yells vengeance
at batman when he's taking him out at the election
that's meant to help him realize what the batman
needs to become a symbol for hope to inspire
people because vengeance is not enough that's what
he means in his final voice over dialogue as he's
saving all these people and the sunlight starts
shining down on them he talks about inspiring
hope and the riddlers watching this all go down
all the way from his cell in arkham asylum going
full-blown crazy pants zodiac killer having a
breakdown all of his mannerisms his nervous tics
the way he speaks his style of writing the ciphers
that he left for batman all based on the real life
zodiac killers actions and behaviors that's why in
my review video earlier this week i called the
batman movie kind of like the zodiac movie done
with batman characters but riddler's watching
this all go down on the television at arkham
because the news is capturing batman while he's
helping save all these lives in the news broadcast
is hailing him as this mysterious mass figure
inspiring hope becoming this big symbol for gotham
the way that classic comic book batman inspires
the people of gotham riddler starts having a
full-blown mental breakdown panic attack about
how it wasn't supposed to end like this and in
the cell next to his you hear a voice it's barry
keoghan's mystery character speaking to him saying
isn't that just terrible him raining on your
parade like that talking about the batman what
is it they say one day you're on top the next
you're a clown everyone in my theater at both of
my screenings just flipped out in the audience
when he said this then he says let me tell you
there are worse things than being and trails off
he was about to say there are worse things than
being a clown just further teasing himself as
the new version of the joker before he started
calling himself the joker he's not wearing the
white makeup but they keep showing his character
in the cell next to riddler and silhouette so you
get glimpses of his body in his face you can kind
of see some scars on his face but obviously this
is meant to be a totally different version so it's
not going to be exactly like heath ledger's
scarred joker face and then he tells riddler
hey don't be sad you did so well and you know
gotham loves a comeback story that's meant to be
both a reference to the riddler returning as full
comic book version of the riddler in the sequels
but also this new version of the joker coming back
so to speak like the joker character coming back
after we just saw jared leto joker joaquin phoenix
joker heath ledger's joker during the dark knight
and riddler asks him who are you and he replies
that's the question isn't it riddle me this
using the riddler's trademark catchphrase the
less of them you have the more one is worth
and riddler correctly guesses a friend meaning
that riddler and joker will eventually team up
and either escape arkham together or eventually
they'll just be working together in the sequels
in the joker starts laughing his new version of
the classic joker laugh like full on hyena laugh
it sounds totally different from all the
previous joker laughs mark hamill's joker
laugh joaquin phoenix's joker laughs jared letos
heath ledger's joker laugh because this is going
to be matt reeve's new take on the joker i'm
sure there'll be some similarities once they
fully reveal his look but mostly it's meant
to be a totally new iteration of the character
the deleted scene with his joker character that
matt reeves was talking about in the past couple
of days was batman meeting joker inside arkham
asylum he filmed the batman vs joker scene and
it took place when batman goes to arkham to see
riddler and ask him why he's been writing to him
before the big final attack on the election matt
reeves said during their scene joker just provokes
batman as he passes by his cell and they kind
of go at it a little and what he wanted to do
was use the scene to show that batman in this
new version of the joker had history before he
started using the joker name because just like all
the other villains in the movie like the penguin
the riddler catwoman they're gonna do a new
version of a joker origin story through the
sequel movies so this verse of the joker has not
actually become the joker yet he's just another
crazy person that batman has captured and put in
arkham and that's how he wound up in a cell right
next to riddlers they did say one of the batman
hbo series is going to focus on arkham asylum and
the villains there so it's possible that they
also use that hbo series to further develop
joker and riddler characters in addition to other
batman villains i believe they plan on premiering
that series later next year sometime but there is
a post-credits scene not the kind you would expect
but it is a taxing after the credits so if you
haven't seen the movie and you're watching this
video do stay through the rest of the credits
it's meant to be another reference to riddler's
q anon type website group rataalata dot com after
the credits the green text of the website pops up
like someone has just logged in to the website
again to check for another riddler video post
and the green text starts typing goodbye
but then with a question mark and you hear
riddlers breathing underneath his mask like that
really creepy breathing sound that he would make
when he was broadcasting his videos as if he
recorded another new video it's also meant to
be a reference to the riddler's trademark question
mark symbol and him returning in the sequel movies
like this is not goodbye because we're all
coming back in the sequels and also meant to be
a reference to the fact that they are doing sequel
movies goodbye is in this might be the end of this
story but it's not the end of the entire story the
website name rataalata dot com is just spanish for
rat with wings it was meant to be a reference to
carmine falcone's character because falcone was a
rat and falcons also have wings he was the mystery
person who ratted out salmoroni's drug operation
years ago helping install all these powerful
people in the police and the government so that
he could control the city if it wasn't clear how
the riddler learned falcone was behind everything
his job before he started his quest to take them
all down was a forensic accountant working on that
special billion dollar fund thomas wayne created
called the gotham city renewal fund that's how
he had access to all those ledgers from the actual
fund itself and he followed the money trail and it
led back to carmine falcone right now they've been
hyping up the court of owls as the big villains
for the sequel movies along with mr freeze
being another big villain that they'll introduce
the monster who took you from me will soon learn
that revenge is a dish best served cold they
might wind up saving court of owls for the third
film because matt reeves said that he does plan
a trilogy the whole connection to the court of
owl's storyline is the riddler referencing the
founding families of gotham and that's who the
court of owls are they're all made up of the most
powerful families in gotham that created the city
in the movie while he's trying to out thomas wayne
as being connected to all this corruption he talks
about the histories of their families thomas wayne
from the wayne family and his wife martha was
actually martha arkham from the arkham family he
says they were the two founding families of gotham
so batman's mother's family created arkham asylum
in the movie that was because she suffered
from a mental breakdown and needed to go to
an institution so that's why they founded arkham
asylum in the first place because martha wayne's
mother went crazy killed her father she then later
suffered from mental problems and was in and out
of institutions and that's where arkham asylum
came from so it's just teasing this larger darker
history the truth of the history of gotham
and that's when you get into court of owls
and because one of those batman hbo spin-off
series is specifically about arkham asylum
i think they'll also get more into that history
behind arkham asylum the creation of arkham asylum
during that as well so possibly even more court of
owls during that hbo spin-off series matt reeves
the producers have implied that the batman 2
sequel movie won't come for three to four years so
like the next big part of the story moving forward
will take place in all these hbo spin-off series
but i'll cover all the major easter eggs and
clues in my full breakdown video tomorrow make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss that everyone click here
for the batman movie review video and click
here for my new doctor strange 2 x-men video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!